[Music]
and I'll tell you what I'm looking to
hit leaping and he's only about ten feet
to our left Regina King for MVP the 48
year old actress had a close call while
sitting courtside at the New York Knicks
game against the Philadelphia 76ers on
Wednesday she quickly went from
spectator at Madison Square Garden to
part of the game when 76ers player Joel
embiid took a giant leap over her head
as he dove for the ball oh look at that
doing hi oh he just managed to miss
Virgie the NBA star miss Regina but the
guy behind her wasn't quite as lucky
thankfully the if Beale Street could
talk star was a good sport and laughed
off the near miss Tracy Morgan was a
part of the action as well although it's
unclear whether he was trying to take a
picture or shield his own head either
way he was laughing about the whole
thing
Regina took to Twitter following the
close call writing yo Thank You God and
at Joel embiid for your athletic
abilities crisis averted it's kind of
feeling like the year of Regina's right
now
yes Regina is on fire she's got an Oscar
nom for if Beale Street could talk and
is using all that praise to bring
attention to the fight to hire more
women in the film industry she took a
stand during her Golden Globes
acceptance speech in January here's what
she told ET about the response to her
call to action to take the risk
saying something like that and putting
something on myself that was too big the
reception that I'm saving receiving I
don't feel like it is I feel like it's
possible and the reality is all I had to
do was say it see how it landed and so
far so good